Annika Wilker aus Bärenstein im
Erzgebirge denkt derzeit viel an früher
zurück die DDR hatte damals hier ein
abraumfeld für Steinbrocken aus dem
Bergbau angelegt bei trockenem Wetter
trug der Wind den Staub der Felsen dann
manchmal schwadenweise ins Tal also die
Scheiben waren zerschlissen an den
Häusern hat man es gesehen die roten
Schlieren die Wäsche war wohl richtig
rot und es gibt viele Leute die haben
hier Asthma richtig ne und es kommt hier
gerade wirklich zu r aumatisierung ich
habe mit einigen gesprochen
die die haben Angst um ihre Kinder ne
das halt ihren Kindern das halt auch
wieder fährt denn auch heute 30 Jahre
später droht wieder ein abraumfeld
wieder hier in berärenstein im
Erzgebirge um das zu verstehen müssen
wir runter in den Berg 80 m unter
Zinnwald in Sachsen die Bergleute früher
förderten hier Zinn zutage die Bergleute
heute wollen den Schatz der Zukunft
heben Lithium genug für Batterien von
Elektroautos der lei sieht hier aber
erst einmal nur einen
Steinbrocken muss mal ganz naiv fragen
wie viel lizium ist denn hier drinne in
diesem Klumpen also in diesem Erdstück
sind 3500 ppm ppm heißt Parts per
million also Teilchen pro Million das
sind
0,35% in dem Erz und also ein paar
Krümel eigentlich eigentlich nur ein
paar Krümel in dem zinwaldit in der
mineralansicht sind 1,5 bis 1,6% Lithium
enthalten wir sehen hier nur die ausläuf
ein 200 m mächtigen Lagerstätten Körpers
tief unter uns Preis und Nachfrage
machen den aufwendigen Abbau selbst
dieser Krümel rentabel der Berg könnte
Lithium für 200.000 Elektroautos liefern
pro Jahr und das für dre Jahrzehnte ein
multimilliardenschatz doch wer soll ihn
heben die letzte Zeche hier im Revier
Schloss gleich nach dem Mauerfall vor 33
Jahren wo sollen denn die Arbeitskräfte
herkommen haben die Sorgen nicht nein
wir haben die Sorgen nichtit Kräfte
wissen wir in Sachsen ist nicht mehr all
viel verfügbar im aktuellen Maßstab aber
es gibt noch eine Ausbildung in Freiberg
für Bergmänner etc da müssen man
natürlich dann Leute starten die
ausgebildet werden und natürlich auf
alte erfahrene erzgebürgler Bergmänner
zurückgreifen die sind dann ja schon
sehr alt ja aber sie sind n Verfügung
wir haben ja schon Bewerbungen vorliegen
die gesagen okay ich war jetzt 30 Jahre
vielleicht in der Schweiz im Einsatz und
möchte vielleicht die restlichen 10
Jahre noch im ergebirg wieder tätig
werden torsten maachmann hat aber noch
ein anderes Problem Millionen Kilo
Lithium aus dem Berg geholt werden
fallen Milliarden Kilo Abraum an der
soll zum Teil auch oberirdisch gelagert
werden im nahen bererenstein die
Anwohner dort finden das nur so
mittelgut aber wir versuchen wie gesagt
ja mit der Bevölkerung weiterhin im
Gespräch zu bleiben und gemeinsame
Lösung eventuell zu finden wie es für
beide Seiten erträgliches Projekt wird
verstehen sie das dass die Leute nicht
so happy sind wenn da diese vielen
Steine vor ihrer Tür liegen ja das kann
ich natürlich nachvollziehen den
Gedankengang deswegen müssen wir im
Gespräch bleiben wie man für beide sein
viil ich eine gute Lösung findet was
könnte das denn für eine sein z.B eine
gute Lösung das wissen wir jetzt noch
nicht wir haben jetzt sag mal diese zwei
Varianten in in Augenschein genommen und
mit denen werden wir jetzt auch erstmal
weitergehen und das Genehmigungsprozess
wird ja zeigen was dann möglich ist und
was nicht eine der Varianten sieht vor
den Abraum hier im benachbarten
Bärenstein zu lagern 60 Hektar sind
dafür vorgesehen 120 Fußballfelder auf
diesen sogenannten Bergwiesen wir haben
die Gegend im spätsammer besucht und die
Menschen troffen die hier leben den
Biobauer Bernt Seifer z.B der sich
später im Alter am liebsten nur um die
Gäste in seinen ausgebauten
Ferienwohnungen kümmern würde Wohnungen
die dann aber am Rande eines
gerollllfeldes lägen ich kann mir das
sowas nicht vorstellen weil also es ist
also das wä ein Albtraum also für uns
wäre das ein Albtraum weil ich ich bin
hier geboren ich ich wenn es geht und
wenn wir Urlaube haben und wenn die
Interesse haben sich das anzugucken
frche jeden Tag auch wenn es geht mit
die Urlauber mal raus zeigt den
eigentlich von dem Punkt aus was man von
eine wunderschöne Gegend haben also das
war bis Dresden bis zum Königstein bis
sonnstein bis Pirner eigentlich gucken
können und dann vorzustellen dass hier
ein Riesenberg Dreck liegt das ist
natürlich fürchtet Bern Seifert auch den
Wertverlust seines Hofes und seines
Grundstückes dafür findet er auch
Verständnis bei den zuständigen
lokalpitikern die ja eigentlich fast
alles tun um Millionen schwere
Unternehmen in die eigene Stadt zu
locken
Markus Wiesenberg aber das Oberhaupt im
sächsischen Altenberg zeigt sich beim
lithiumabbau hin und her
gerissen wir sind eine gut laufende
Tourismusdestination wir haben über
300.000 Übernachtungen im Jahr das ist
ja alles nach dem Bergbau entstanden und
das wollen wir jetzt grundlegend
eigentlich mit dem neuen Bergbau nie
gefährden das ist so die eine Seite
thmodi und die andere Seite ist
natürlich Gewerbesteuer Arbeitsplätze
dann diesen doch wichtigen Stoff da um
uns abhä unabhängiger von anderen
Ländern zu machen in unserer Gemeinde
abzubauen wäre natürlich auch was für
uns doch es gibt viel zu bedenken dabei
dort unten im Tal bei berenstein z.B
fließt die müklitz eigentlich ein
Bächlein ein Bächlein aber das bei der
letzten großen Flut in Sachsen ganze
Dörfer mit sich riss wir sind hier im
hochwasserentstehungsgebiet wir stehen
hier auf Bergwiesen diese Bergwiesen
haben halt die Möglichkeit
natürlich Wasser zu Speichen zu
speichern wenn diese Bergwiesen weg sind
also wenn die einfach versiegelt werden
dann ist diese Möglichkeit nicht mehr
gegeben es fließt halt einfach in den
Dorfbach rein es fließt in die Bieler
rein es fließt in die Müglitz und dann
ist es da eventuell das
Hochwasser all diese Fragen werden eines
Tages auch ihn beschäftigen dr Bernhard
Krammer hat zum Interview die
bergmannstracht das habit angelegt hier
im sächsischen Oberbergamt wird
entschieden ob der Schatz wirklich
gehoben werden kann die Lagerstätte
allein betrachtet hat für den Geologen
schon ihren
Reiz lagerstät Litium an sich in ihrer
Gänze mit den satellitenlagerstätten die
auch noch drum rum liegen ist
zentraleuropäisch das Größte was wir
Litium haben es ist minerologogisch was
besonderes es ist ein Hartgestein es ist
nicht wie in Südamerika etwas wo man
riesengroße Flächen zerstört sondern es
ist etwas wo man wirklich Erz abbauen
kann und hinterher die Grube schließen
kann ne das muss man immer
berücksichtigen und wir führen hier für
diese nachhaltige Entwicklung
E-Mobilität Akkumulatoren für die
E-Mobilität in Zentraleuropa würden wir
einen Bergbau betreiben unter den
weltweit höchsten Umweltstandards und
Sicherheitsstandards das wäre etwas wo
wir zeigen können wir mein es ernst mit
der Nachhaltigkeit wie das Amt aber
schließlich entscheidet das kann er
jetzt noch nicht sagen noch liege ihm
nicht einmal ein abschließender Antrag
vor wie die Geschichte also ausgeht das
ist offen die Bären Steiner wppnen sich
hier am Abend für ein erstes
sondierungstreffen mit der zinnwalt
Ende Oktober will man sich
zusammensetzen vielleicht kommen dann
Kompromissvorschläge auch für den Abraum
mit auf den
Tisch